we're following a developing story in
Australia this morning where an SUV
slammed into a crowd in the
second-largest city of Melbourne 19
people are injured including four in
critical condition police are calling it
a deliberate act the driver and another
person are in custody the heart of
Melbourne was crowded with Christmas
shoppers Nick Etzel of our partner
Network 10 Australia is there Nick good
morning good morning we now know the
driver was known to police and had a
history of mental health issues the
attack happened at the height of rush
out outside the city's busiest train
station packed with commuters and
Christmas shoppers emergency responders
rushed to treat the injured who were
thrown in the air when a white SUV
plowed into pedestrians at full speed
witnesses said it was like a bomb going
off here back for gondolas penis was
cracked with a boy down
the car would just speed up in purpose
this all should tell me and she's just
like really shaky at least 19 people
were injured several are in critical
condition Australian police say it was
no accident at this stage we believe is
that a deliberate act can I repeat that
at this stage we believe it is a
deliberate act however we do not know
the motivation and is still early stages
of the investigation an off-duty police
officer arrested the driver a 32 year
old Australian citizen of Afghan descent
at the scene the second man was arrested
but it's unclear if he's linked to the
incident the attack appears to follow a
deadly trend of terrorists using
vehicles as weapons a truck attack in
New York in October left 8 dead 13 were
killed in Barcelona before that and last
year a deadly rampage in France claimed
the lives of 86 people police say the
second man arrested was filming the
incident and had knives held in his bag
security has now been stepped up around
Melbourne go
alright Nichols thank you very much
reporting from Melbourne